the jury were directed to deliver a
verdict of lawful killing
they did that but then there was a
narrative
questioned
aspect to the verdicts that they were
also delivering and on that they
believed that there was a missed
opportunity by the probation service to
recall sudeshiman to prison in the days
before this attack that would have
prevented this attack had he of course
been recalled to prison now that related
to a shopping expedition that he did in
the days before the attack he was seen
by police surveillance teams who had
been following him the police have
believed that he posed a very
significant real threat to the public
that he would launch a terrorist attack
that it was a matter of when not if he
would launch that attack so he was the
subject of round-the-clock surveillance
well a couple of days before he launched
the attack on the 2nd of february last
year he was seen
at a store buying a roll of brown parcel
tape also some plastic bottles of soft
drink and some tin foil now or on their
own that might not seem all that
suspicious but the police know
that from previous terrorist attacks
those types of items have been used in
the construction of fake suicide vests
so it immediately raised alarm bells
with the police there was a meeting that
took place with the prison and probation
service
to try to determine whether
the purchase of these items
may have
con
have a breached the
the restrictions
that he was placed under on his release
from prison now he had been
originally sentenced to 40 months in
prison for the
dissemination of extremist material
and he was
subject to a number of licensed
conditions now the probation service
having looked at what his behavior was
and buying these items believed that he
had not crossed the threshold
for
breaching those conditions so decided
not to recall him to prison however the
jury
in reaching their verdict believed that
there was a missed opportunity that
actually given the concerns that the
police had
uh from what they had seen in previous
attacks that it did amount to a breach
of his conditions and he should have
been recalled to prison so a missed
opportunity there by the probation
service the two other questions they
were asked to consider really were
centered around the actions of the
police one was whether the police should
have searched the room he was staying at
he was staying
at a probation hostel not far from
streatham high road after his release
from prison in the days before the
attack
the jury though concluded though
that in terms of searching
that probation hostel
that the police did the right thing in
not doing that that it would have been
difficult for them to do it
to try to
organize for members of staff in that
hostel to carry out
a search a delicate search of this young
man's room at times when he wasn't there
and he was there
an awful lot in the days before the
attack he hardly left his room
and the third uh
question that they were asked to
consider was really around this young
man when he left on the morning of the
attack of the afternoon of the attack it
was 22 minutes past one in the afternoon
that he left the hostel
to go to stratham high road at that
point
they were asked should the police have
stopped and searched him because of his
behavior he was walking quite slowly at
times he doubled back on himself at
times but the jury again felt that the
police actions in just following him
quite closely there were nine
surveillance officers some of those
officers were armed
some were in cars one was on a motorbike
others were on foot
because of his actions
they believed that the police were
actually justified in just continuing to
follow him rather than stopping him so
really i think as far as the police
handling of the surveillance operation
surrounding sudetshaman and the response
to him launching the attack that day
they have been cleared by the jury their
actions were appropriate but as i say
the probation service
coming in for
some criticism the jury believing that
there was a missed opportunity by them
to recall sudha shiman to prison for
going out buying items which the
authorities believed
rang alarm bells with them
because of the fact that they may well
have been and in fact of course they
were ultimately used in the construction
of a fake suicide vest when he launched
that attack on the 2nd of february last
year
and in terms of the operation to
stop him once he launched the attack it
all unfolded very quickly 62 seconds
from the moment he emerged from that low
price store which he ducked into to grab
a 20 centimeter long kitchen knife
rip the plastic
covering from that knife and then run
out into the street so just a minute
later the police who were chasing him
down the street he managed to stab two
people but no more than that before the
police caught up to him and were able to
open fire and bring an end to this
attack and ultimately of course an end
to suda sheman's life at 20 years of age